One often overlooked stitch pattern is
thread lace, also called punch lace.
This is for automatic patterning
machines, punch card or electronics.
The technique is similar to
fair isle, but it has no floats.
It combines a fine yarn with a heavier
yarn, the stitches knit with the fine yarn
create open spaces that look like holes.
No stitches are transferred.
And set up correctly with
a good choice of yarns.
You'll easily knit, a lace-like fabric.
Again, similar to fair
isle needles are selected.
Needles that are selected in middle
position are knit with the yarn from the
front feeder, which is our thin yarn.
And the yarn and the back
feeder, the thicker yarn doesn't
knit, those selected needles.
Unlike fair isle, needles that
are in working position knit,
both yarns eliminating the floats.
In this example, I used a finer yarn and
a similar green color in the heavier yarn.
Something to consider.
For most of the design, both yarns are
knitting together at the same time.
Be sure to keep this in mind when
you're selecting the weights of yarn
to combine, this is an interesting
fabric, but we can improve on this.
I replaced the thin green
yarn with a variegated thread.
This is actual quilting thread on cones.
I think it's designed
for long arm quilting.
This is a much more interesting fabric.
You can clearly see the
individual stitches that are
knit with the thread alone.
Here's another example.
At this gauge a heavier yarn is
jazzed up with the variegated thread.
That's the bulky machine.
But here's my favorite.
Take a look at thread
lace on the standard.
Same concept, but I really love this.
White sewing thread with a white yarn.
White yarn with a colored sewing thread.
White yarn with another
verigated sewing thread.
You can really see how knitting the two
yarns together changes the white knitting
and it makes it something really special.
Now in the past, this technique
has always been demonstrated, being
worked with a fine, clear filament.
Because the filament
didn't have any color.
It really does look like lace.
But I don't know about you,
it never appealed to me.
I couldn't get excited
about this technique until
I played with sewing thread.
Looking at stitch patterns that
are good for this technique.
You're not going to want too many needles
next to each other being selected.
Notice that the white
square is the heavier yarn.
The black squares
represent the finer yarn.
So you don't want a bunch of
black squares next to each other.
Here at the machine,
there are four stitches that
are knit with the finer yarn,
but there's a long float behind.
So keep this in mind when selecting
patterns to use for thread lace.
I hope you'll give this a try.
Thread lace is an interesting
alternative to other stitch
patterns and plain old stockinette.
And I'm sure that you can come
up with some other beautiful
combinations for your knitting.